INSTRUCTOR: Hello
visitors, it is
time to set up shop with our
Tableau Desktop application,
and that's what this adventure
guide will take you through.
At this point, you should have
requested a student license
for the Tableau
Desktop, and should
have that key and the
ability to download it
onto your own computer.
So I want to take you through
a little bit about Tableau
and why we choose to
use it in this course.
There are lots of great
ways to visualize your data.
Excel is one of the basics.
Power BI is also
created by Microsoft.
There's Domo, which is
located in Silicon slopes,
in the Lehigh area.
And then there's Tableau.
And Tableau is an
industry leader
that's being used by quite a few
companies because of the maps
and dashboard capabilities.
And so we've selected this
platform for this course,
although many of the
concepts you'll be learning
can be transferred to any
visualization that you make.
So Tableau was designed
to solve a problem.
And what was that problem?
It was the barriers in getting
all of that information
into some sort of
a visualization
where we could begin
to see insights.
And so we know that
data is powerful.
We have data, but
there was definitely
a bottleneck in harvesting the
data and getting those insights.
And so not only did Tableau
take advantage of this,
but as I mentioned those
other companies too.
And so there are quite a
few software developers who
are trying to make it
easier for the user
to visualize the massive
amounts of data we have.
So as I mentioned,
right now, they
are the leader in data
flow visualization.
And many companies
do use Power BI just
simply because of the
packaging that you can buy
and bundle, Excel and
Word and so forth.
But Tableau's strength lies
in the map's capability
and in their dashboards.
We'll see what
happens in five years.
It's a market economy, so we'll
see if things change or not.
But it really is
very user friendly,
which is another reason why we
like to use it in this course,
because students with
no prior experience,
even in visualization, can
quickly drag and drop and begin
to feel confident in their
visualization skills.
So Tableau does invest lots
of research and development.
They have an extensive
Tableau help videos,
and I'll show you where
you can find those.
And there's a huge
community of Tableau users.
And so this is a great platform
for us to use in this class.
So there's also a
lot more that Tableau
can be used for
machine learning,
there's statistics natural
language processing,
and basically, its
purpose is to augment
the human creative and
analytical abilities
and to share ideas that promote
the educated use of data.
So that sounds very corporate.
But in reality, if we can
synthesize and understand
our data, even our own
self data, then maybe
we can begin to change
habits that could
lead to healthier happy lives.
Our companies can be more
efficient with their resources,
et cetera, et cetera.
So there's a lot to be learned.
So when we dive
into Tableau, you'll
notice that there are a
couple of different panes.
This is not actually
the home page,
and I'll show you
that in a moment.
But this is the
data source pane.
And you can see that on the
lower left hand corner here,
it says data source.
And this is where you'll
be bringing in your data.
This is one of the places and
probably the primary place.
But this is the data pane.
This left area where it's going
to show the sheets that you
have, and then you can drag them
and drop them into this Canvas.
So that Canvas area does
show that connection
between your sheets and other
sheets that you might bring in.
The Canvas is the logical
layer where you can create
relationships between these.
And then to get to
the physical layer,
you can even double
click this Orders.
It's not live right now.
And then it can open up a
table where you can join
or you can do other types
of relationships there.
This is called the data grid.
And this is where
all of those columns
and rows from your CSV file
or Excel file or JSON file
will be placed.
And we'll get into that
in a little bit more,
but that's called
the data grid area.
And this is the--
oh, I should say for the data
grid that Tableau displays
the first 1,000 rows of data
contained in the data source.
So it only shows
the first 1,000.
So if you have 10,000 rows, it's
not going to show all of those.
But it does reside
within the file.
The next one is the
meta grid table.
And this is showing the fields
that are in your data sources
as rows.
So we have order ID and
you can see order IDs here,
order dates here,
order dates here.
And it begins to tell you
again that physical table,
the remote field and the type,
and so those are also up here.
This is the Tableau workspace.
So this is where you're going
to be spending more of your time
as you drag these
fields onto this Canvas
into the columns or the
rows, and as you begin
to work within this space.
But that's called the
Tableau workspace.
And this is called
the view area.
I did reference
it to the Canvas.
So view or Canvas would be fine.
But that is the
space where you can
begin to make your tables, your
bar charts, your histograms,
your scatter plots, et cetera.
Up here in the
upper left corner,
this is the workbook name
so that you know which
workbook you're working within.
This whole file is the workbook.
And these are the
three shelf cards.
If you will, you've got
pages, filters, and marks.
And those have a lot of
drag and drop capabilities
as you want to filter things or
create pages or the marks card.
These are called the shelves.
And that's where you find
your columns and rows.
So typical when you're
thinking about your xy axis.
So those are the
columns and rows.
And that's called the shelves.
The toolbar is here at the top.
So there's icons that you'll
become more familiar with
to refresh your data to
bring in new data sources
to do ascending versus
descending sorts.
And then there's
also this area up
here where you'll have dropdown
menus to then continue to refine
what your visualizations are.
This little Tableau icon
is the Start Here button.
And so that will return you back
to that main Start Here page
that you'll see when you
first launch Tableau.
Down here at the bottom
is the status bar.
It can tell you where you're
at, and you can't even tell you
how many data points there are.
And you can see that there
are different sheet tabs here.
So the whole thing
is called a workbook.
And these are called sheets.
And there are icons, where
you can add more sheets.
That's this icon this
one with the four grids.
That's actually
for the dashboard.
All right, file
types really quickly.
There's a .twb and this stores a
visualization without the source
data.
Sometimes in this class,
students save .twb because maybe
that was the default setup and
it does not have the source
data.
So when they go to launch
it, it doesn't work.
I'll show you what that means.
But basically there's a file
type with an x at the end.
That's what you need.
But this one has no source data.
The tds, it stores the
server address, password,
and other information
to access a data source.
So if I've got a SQL server
or something else and I need
to create that connection,
I'm going to use .tds.
We won't be using this
extension in our class.
There's the .tbm which stores
a connection to a worksheet
in another Tableau workbook.
So again, when you start
building lots of workbooks
and dashboards, you will
be working with coworkers
potentially where you'll need to
make sure that you're speaking
to one another and
that said .tbm.
We won't be using in that class.
And then you have the .tde where
the Tableau data is filtered,
and there's an
aggregated extract there.
So we will not be
using this either.
This is to speed
connections along,
but it is a way to get the
extracted data that you use.
This is the file
type that you will
be saving 99.9% of the time.
Nothing is really 100%, but
it's called a twbx file.
So the way I pronounce it,
it's a packaged workbook.
It stores the extracted data
and all of your visualizations,
and you can also use it in
the Tableau reader, which
for clients that may not want
to purchase Tableau Desktop,
they can get a free Tableau
reader so they can still
see your visualizations, so
when you save it as a twbx file.
So those are the file types.
This last one, double
check when you're saving
that it has that x on the end.
So there are additional
resources here.
I'll provide this slide
deck in the notes.
But there's different
source 1 and source 2
where you can go check out
stuff in the Tableau help area,
where it points to all this same
information I just outlined.
All right, so now
it's your turn.
So to complete this final
part of the adventure guide,
you first need to have Tableau.
So if you don't have it,
pause, go back find the link,
request the student version
student license for Tableau.
They provide a key to
your email address.
Be sure you use your
student email address,
and they're very quick
about getting you that key.
And then you just enter that
key into that 14 day trial.
You get it for free for 14
days, but in that window,
you need to update that
with the actual key.
So we're going to go ahead and
just do the six step process.
We're going to a data
source from kaggle.com.
If you don't have
an account, you
need to create a free account.
This could be a great source for
some project data in the future.
We're going to find a data
source called All Shark Tank
(US) pitches & deals.
We're going to download it.
We're going to launch
Tableau Desktop.
We're going to go under
connect and under File
and we're going to add
that CSV file in there.
We're going to go
to the worksheet.
We're going to create a
really simple bar chart.
And then we're going
to take a screenshot.
And then you're
going to turn it in.
So let's go ahead
and head to Kaggle.
So you should go ahead and just
make yourself a free version
at kaggle.com.
You see here and
in this search bar,
I'm going to go ahead
and put All Shark Tank
(US) pitches & deals.
And there's one data set.
This is five years ago.
This is what you want.
So I'm going to go ahead
and download that and put
that in my download folder.
You can read more about the
data set et cetera, et cetera.
And again, great place to
explore potential places
that you might find data.
So I'm going to go ahead
and close that down
and pull up Tableau.
So this is the initial
page for Tableau.
And you can see I've already
got some previous work that I've
got just showing here.
There is the connection
to a server to a file.
This is where you
will most likely
be using only for this class.
And then other servers
and these sample data
sets, which are awesome.
And we use them a
lot in our demos.
So I'm going to go ahead here.
And since I have a CSV file--
see I can do a text file, a
JSON, PDF, Excel, et cetera--
I'm going to go to
more, and then I'm
just going to navigate to my
Shark tank pitches and deal CSV
file.
And then I can just open that.
Once I open that, it'll go
straight to this data source
area where I showed you
earlier that this is the space.
And you can see
what it's doing is
it's going to pull in
that particular data set
onto my Canvas.
And you can see Shark
Tank pitches deals.
All of this, you
probably don't have this.
This is just adding in a whole
bunch of other CSV files.
I've used to make some other
visualizations for other stuff.
So ignore that.
That's not going to
be on your Tableau.
So you've seen all these kinds
of things we just talked about.
We'll get into detail in
future adventure guides
about what these mean,
what this means, et cetera.
What I want you to do right now
is just go to the worksheet.
So see how it's pointing.
Hey go to this worksheet.
Just click on that.
Now I've moved from
the data source.
So I can go back to the
data source to that sheet.
And again, this is
that view area that
Canvas rows and
columns et cetera,
I've got my various
things in here.
All I want you to do here
is to take the Deal Shark
and drop that on Columns.
So pretty easy.
Just click that and drag that to
columns and then drop that in.
And then I want you to take this
Sharktankpitches deals, which
is basically counting all of
the rows in that data source,
and I want to just
put that on Rows.
So this is a little funky
because this is a null category
that is the highest.
We won't go into that.
But basically, you need to
take a screenshot of this,
and you need to make
sure it's time stamped.
So in a Mac that's in the
upper right hand corner,
I believe, on a PC that's in
the lower left or right corner,
make sure you've
got a date stamp
and timestamp so that you can
get all the points for this.
So let me go back to
my presentation here.
Your submission,
I just mentioned
needs to be time
stamped screen capture.
Upload that to the AG
Set Up Shop Submission,
and then you'll get
your full points
and you'll be ready to do some
more visualizations in class.
Happy visiting.